and this is episode 10 Murdock versus
Nelson Nelson versus Murdock it is not
active versus its VDOT as in Murdock
penalties
yeah because vs. would probably be a
little bit more entertaining what we got
in this episode this is not a bad
episode but Baike this could have been
chopped in half
you know I completely agree thank you
well most conscious defenders of this
show but this is the first episode where
because I know you there were moments
like this and foggy I'm like this was
the first one I saw at the first time
I'm like okay I may be foggy down with
this emphasis here's the thing the
actors are really good even when foggy
has to say a dumb line or something like
that you know it's like he's fine it's
just that it's not needed and this is
the perfect case of the everything in
the acting and what they said before
it's already there you don't need to go
this long as acting in this episode is
not bad it's the writing does him no
favors
yeah because it's it's okay acting but
after about five minutes of it you're
like you get it the college flashbacks
just went on forever and it's that same
tone of voice like I'm acting like a
goofy college student and like it
probably would have been fine for like
just a few minutes but I felt like that
scene just drank oh and the final image
of you know him putting the sign in the
trash can I'm not gonna lie I was kind
of like really you know in any other
show you know in so many other shows I
would probably okay but again it's that
high standard that it raises itself up
to and I still do not see this as like a
bad or terrible episode I mean it's the
fact that everything else has been
raised so higher than what we have
something even heated this episode but
it just needs that I think you put it
best it just needed to be cut in half
there's only so much of foggy guard
look that like I can take it it's his
performance isn't bad the problem is it
was set fine the first time the hizzy
final an easy I love acting can be a
little grating but it is realistic like
I'm like no I believe it it's that it
just didn't need to go on that long like
that style of like the always crying
about oh no it's very window staring out
the window and the the puppy-dog look
like it would be fine then short little
bursts but like this was just too much
foggy and then even Murdock near the end
just a little weepy eyed and stuff how's
that all I can do is after a while it's
just yeah it's just too much like it did
rip like I I felt like it was getting
very Frodo and Sam like in a sort of
bromance way where I'm just like okay
like in the college scenes I remember we
were watching it just a few but it's a
guy who's like oh well you just kiss
like it just he's gonna make a joke
about being a gay couple
it's just overkill um and I I have no
problem with that if they really were a
gay couple like that would be an
interesting story to tell but if you're
not going that route it just is yeah
just to overkill yeah and again I think
because really cuz the writing is so
good in the acting so good it's kind of
like what we said in the last one where
I was like that face he gave when he saw
the body of the old woman it's like we
got in that hit us so hard it's like
that's enough and then when you can't
keep going with it
exactly that's overkill on this one it's
just most of the episode where I think
yeah I think about half of it would have
been fine um and Huggy is better like I
love foggy I loved his character I loved
the actor I I actually genuinely do like
the performances but their best in short
spurts like you drag it out longer than
the needs to be and it wears out its
welcome much faster than say like you
know Dena here's performances FISC or
something and I know what they're doing
they're doing it like a trial like well
I bring this up well you know your honor
I defend
that I beloved life you remember this
case while you remember beside its I get
it but we kind of know it gets to a
point where we don't really care with
you I'll come when the whole theme of
this episode is conflict
you've got Gow and Fisk in conflict and
she brings up the point she's like a man
in conflict can't you know house divided
based we cannot stand like you either
have to be a press or a savior like
you've changed now you're more emotional
you know you're this and that and it's
true Fisk is in conflict now because he
has Vanessa and the difference like the
interesting differences Murdock's
conflict is different Murdock is all
about should I stay in the shadows
should I kill Fisk take that extra step
Fisk's conflict was should I go into
public should I come out of the shadows
and just as Fisk said you know I as he
realized that he got emotional
particularly with the Russians he's like
that's the way to break a man you know
as to tuck his heartstring somehow you
know bathed like now we see it happening
in Reverse to Fisk because he exposed
himself at this party and how people
were getting poisoned yeah well and the
whole time when I mean that incredible
you know I didn't see it coming
my only guess is that's gal I don't know
I know you know but I don't actually
know who it is that's my only guess I
have no clues outside that the only
thing I saw is that I always forget its
name that the panel's guy um Leland yeah
is that it almost looks like you know
he's looking around and then dropped his
glass like almost like oh I gotta keep
up appearances but and I know this I
noticed that too I think the first time
I saw him I was looking at him like hmm
because I did see what when I noted out
the champey I was like who else needs a
drink as much and I didn't see if he
actually sipped it or not but ya know
it's plain when I saw the person drop
okay some sort of murder then I saw
another person drive champagne I'm like
huh could be the champagne and then I'm
like oh
I was so much more investor sure it was
so much more invest in the two of them
that when they cut back to boggy and
murder I got my fuck off what's going on
with the party
lately agree because like then the
episode ended then my wife is just like
we have to watch the next one out I'm
like I know because this is like I did
not want to cut back this is probably
the most time it gets like I'm gonna go
home and go back to a two-time of the
office and film and study you know I got
work to do in stuff this is the time
round just like in a good way because I
want to see what happens but in a
pissed-off way because it's like damn it
we could have been getting this
information instead of watching group
counseling with the two of them and I
usually love episodes where it goes
slower and you dive more into the
character and stuff I uh it's very
strange I would have thought the reveal
that foggy now knows that Murdock is the
man in the black mask or daredevil to be
if you told me that in this series that
they were doing an episode a whole
episode dedicated to it on paper I've
been like this is gonna be amazing
yeah visit and that's why I came out of
it just feeling very strange like huh
that was nowhere near as good as it was
gonna be it wasn't bad oh oh I just
figured out one main problem with those
flashbacks everything was a positive
memory everything yeah there was no
conflict to begin with so I said you
killed many people and there's only so
much of that style of acting out of him
and I said the writers aren't doing in
favors he always said foggy always has
to be those flashbacks hey I'm the wild
and crazy guy amend murder yes there was
very smiles casually and says things in
short and it feels less realistic yeah
it feels like okay this is being used as
a device and I'm sure they're really
going to stay apart and I'm sure they're
never going to get back together as a
Wofford I'm sure that's gonna happen I
mean it's it's one of the things we're
playing and I say this in the same way
we talk about avatar how there are no
Bad Bad episodes that it's just it's
we're judging the best from the not is
best but this section those flashbacks
to me probably the weakest
parts of the series for me like right
there it was the first time I really
felt like wow I am NOT interested kind
of getting annoyed slowly like it's the
first time which is which is good I mean
were so far into the series like most of
it shows by now I've had like a ton of
moments where I mean it's like oh my god
but most of them might be pretty okay
with this is the first time like I'm
kind of actively boring in it I would
argue that them talking you know at
first is great I thought they were
playing a great and wonderful but again
it's not their fault it just when I'm
way too long I thought I really went on
I would still kind of argue that the one
where he's stuck in the place with the
Russian you know it has to keep him
alive and said that's probably still
Maggie's favor because it was just so
boring to look at a cyber very very
offensive this at least every time to
cut back to the kid it was good that is
true well of them talking one even the
flashback that was viewing I will say
this you're probably right just because
more stuff happened than this even with
the problems I'm but I'm saying only
those parts of this episode I'm not
saying I have a problem with the other
parts of the episode because the other
parts the episode we're really good yeah
the more you know with Fisk's mother
yeah no I definitely didn't see that
coming I was gonna be along here again
or something more more conflict now Ben
Eurex got the conflict of like do I keep
investigating Fisk or do I you know do
what's right by my wife hatred no no
when when she suddenly said you know hi
handsome again it's like oh it's like
now you get it and that was pretty
heartbreaking but you know even that
conversation was just like yeah okay
what's going on with King but again I'd
be really picky now she must have known
she did know that was Fisk's mother
going in right oh yeah I mean I was
guessing they otherwise says that would
be the mother fucking what the hell
coincidence enough spoil it for you and
say yes yeah I mean no I deal with that
but just cuz like that that was my
immediate thought I'm like well she had
to know cuz I love espares the world's
biggest coincidence how don't you know
why didn't she
say you know on the way over fucking
fuck oh and Jesse you don't go out I
mean - no come with me the same let's
check the place that's just not gonna
rain but I said no you go just said holy
fucking shit this mother Oh
but again what TV storytelling why is
that that wouldn't worked as well and
that's an it yeah I mean it's still it's
it's not bad I mean it's we always seem
to get like the most emotional over
stuff that's actually not really that
bad you know but I think it's because we
cared so much on everything else it's
everything else in this episode was so
good yeah that's part of it so um so
yeah I mean it again it's I would say
this is necessarily nitpicking as if it
was slow and I think people that want to
would probably say yeah this did feel
kind of slow and then I I have no idea I
haven't read any reviews of the show
episode by episode so I don't know what
audience reaction was to this man I mean
all I can say is that yeah I don't even
think it's nitpicky I think honestly it
was a weak section of this episode and
I'm kind of the show altogether like I
kind of want a rewrite of it because I'm
like to me it should be a scene that
really resonates with me and it
strangely enough didn't yeah but I mean
it's it's one problem another was really
good show like I'm gonna make this show
it's just one was like they do so well
then like oh like so close yeah I really
would argue they're they're kind of too
good they did you know they did the
length that most normal shows would do
it but you get the picture so quickly
and so well that when you do it the
normal mouths like no no we we get it
and we're done now this is just kind of
repeat so like I said I think and what
we're feeling it's like we already feel
it and they're trying to emphasize it
even more and it's not needed so it's
one of those things where it's like I
think I just did their job too well you
know with everything else I pretty much
agree yeah that's terrible and it's not
like you know our first bad episode I
mean like you said just varying levels
of you know what's this wasn't better to
me the scenes that didn't work in this
episode didn't work more than in the
warehouse episode but overall this
so it was better because it had better
scenes with Fiske and Gao and Vanessa
and the poisoning and the you know all
of that so it's it's you know it's pick
your poison I guess don't kill me
wait yes with poison so yeah that's
about it we will see that the next one
later